peu
non
devant chez claude françois vous
l'attendez souvent oui toutes les
semaines
oui prayssas et pourquoi pas ce qu'on
leur en donne alors qu'est ce qui
représente pour vous symbole non parce
que j'adore la plus dynamique qui est le
plus jeune du réseau et de magnifiques
couleurs trop vieux pour vous un
organisme qui chante très bien il paraît
jeune âge il a pour vous nous attendons
pour moi il s'agit vous êtes toutes
amoureuses de lui oui
auj
[Musique]
l'impression se fait d'avoir 4 millions
de femmes ont cette agréable ce soit des
fans de ce soit de façon générale quand
on me dit tiens quelqu'un qui t'aime
bien vraiment même si à la limite tu te
dis il a l'intérêt à dire ça même assez
extrême limite du 10 mai ça crie quand
même plaisir qu'ils sont obligés de me
le dire
alors quand on dit quelqu'un t'aime bien
ça fait toujours plaisir chez moi je
reprends toujours et aucune comparaison
bien sûr le genre pan j'ai un chien et
un chat et tous les deux mains d'avoir
quand j'arrive au tce en ville que le
chat de la remue pas parce qu'en général
c'est parce qu'il est pas content le
chat vient rhône etc
alors je les aime parce qu'il m'aime je
dire c'est élémentaire comme sentiment
alors quand les gens tu aimes bien pour
l'utiliser un bien aussi puis ça fait
plaisir que les gens à venir
j'aime pas que le transforme truc qu'il
est vachement efféminé vous êtes fan
oui beaucoup et vous avez-vous 13 ans et
demi non mes 14 ans dans une semaine
depuis combien de temps vous aimez
claude haut depuis 4 5 ans qu'est ce que
vous feriez pour lui pas l'impossible en
tout cas non oui très fan depuis combien
de temps et puis 12 13 ans depuis le ses
débuts vous pensez qu'il a vieilli au
nom est toujours resté le même toujours
le jeune je le connais depuis toujours
et vraiment il est formidable
extraordinaire qu'est ce que vous aimez
chez lui son style son fils de
perfection absolument tout il est
parfait du point de vue de tout au tout
vraiment je crois que c'est des gens qui
sont imbéciles et c'est abusé de là il
sait manipuler les gens mais d'une façon
faut me l'a vraiment c'est les gens qui
sont comme celui qui est merveilleux
pourquoi vous suivez claude françois de
tourner en tournée est ce qu'on aime
bien vous ceux là mêmes raisons qui vous
poussent à quitter paris et faire du
stop pour venir à amiens bat claude
françois oui et vous moi c'est pareil et
toutes les semaines vous faites ça est
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un mythe
claude françois sans doute
enfin je suppose je me raconte la part
des filles sûrement oui
[Musique]
public c'est comme un chien qui sont
dans un couloir il est là il est prêt au
pire au meilleur
si vous arrivez avec des muscles d'un
pas décidé il a peur de vous si vous
arrivez légèrement flageolant et vous
moeurs et sincèrement pourquoi je ne
prends pas le but vide à un chien seul
angle négatif des choses au contraire je
compare lui qu'un chat sous l'angle
instinctif de la chose il est pour ou
contre
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes allé jusqu'au bout comme ça
jusqu'à nice on stoppe oui cette partie
combien de jours à jour le soir du gala
et vos parents vous laisse partir bien
c'est pourquoi vous aimez claude
françois est ce qu'ils chantent n'ya
est-ce qu'il vous voyez vous a remarqué
et a dit quelques chose qu'est ce qui
vous a dit oh vous êtes amoureuse de lui
non qu'est ce que vous pensez des filles
qui vous accompagne à chaque gala des
finissants qui suivent toujours cc comme
c'est comme le fromage on aime bien le
matin peut-être un peu moins le soir ça
dépend enfin disons que je m'en contente
idéalement que j'en suis positivement
heureux et puis que d'autres fois le
m'ennuie profondément
[Musique]
pas
je vais rentrer dans les secrets je ne
bois pas d'alcool du tout par contre je
vois un peu de whisky avant d'entrer sur
scène pour être un peu vivre un peu
déséquilibré par rapport à mon équilibre
jésuites presque de la situation
[Musique]
oh
boucle
au hockey
combien de personnes dans votre équipe
j'en ai 27 dire 27 27 personnes sur
scène il y en a à peu près je reconnais
19 très exactement et puis tous les
autres tournent autour il est à peu près
donc huit personnes qui tournent autour
qui sont très importantes également
qu'on ne voit pas et techniciens les
chaleur du son les éclairagistes les
hommes à la poursuite tout ça
[Musique]
et c'est mignon dunn qu'il ait fait ce
soir-là une exception il est sorti un
peu plus tôt voici le résultat
[Musique]
m
éclats
[Musique]
non
claude
[Musique]
ah oui c'est vrai qu'au bureau il ya les
arrivées des courriers assez compliquée
en est et vos débuts à une fille donc
qu'est devenue la chef depuis c'est le
plus ancien qui est là depuis 15 ans
s'appelle josette
et puis on en rajoute et 6,6 me semble
ça fait 6 + hs a fait cet été quelques
fois il ya du renfort d'année parce
qu'avec le climat ça change quand il
fait plus chaud il ya un peu plus
créative et puis quand il fait un peu
plus frais ça se calme un petit peu
[Musique]
josette vous êtes responsable du
courrier du fan club de claude combien
de lettres par semaine une trentaine de
milles environ pour le moment et ça ne
fait que s'accroître et vous êtes
combien pour trier tout ça sommes sept
et en a marre on arrive à peu près à 100
1000 par mois pour le moment un petit
peu de mal à y arriver mais le courrier
vient de toute la france et même de
l'étranger de france particulièrement
mais aussi d'étranges et même des états
unis et du canada en ce moment toute
l'europe écrit toute l'europe oui
belgique suisse italie mais enfin même
haïti la guadeloupe en ce moment parce
que tu as dit à une femme séjour et on
reçoit des lettres illustrées très
coloré il ya combien de fans à peu près
dans toute l'europe dans toute l'europe
je pense c'est difficile de donner un
chiffre mais on fourchette une
fourchette 3 4 millions de fans 3 4030
opinion c'est réellement d'après les
récents sondages qu'on a fait c'est pas
un chiffre qui grossissent et un livret
est ce que tu te rends compte que tous
les gens qui travaillent pour toi sont
des fans oui ça sûrement d'abord parce
que la première question occupe est une
fan donc elles ne pourraient avoir des
conversations très précise que des
conversions de fans aiment prétend
n'avoir d'autre donc je suppose qu'elle
a la carte blanche a choisi qui veulent
fait venir qu'elle veut donc elle
organise son système mais je suppose
qu'elle prend des fans et j'en connais
certaines qui sont des femmes qui
travaillent au bureau et qui après tout
la nuit après avoir travaillé
sérieusement d'ailleurs parce que dans
la journée je ne vois pas enfin fonçant
montmagny faire pipi de temps en temps
pour vous rencontrer dans des escaliers
mais en général sont sérieusement
cloître et là où un travail et puis dans
le reste de la soirée de la nuit
d'ailleurs quand toutes les autres fans
parisienne elles suivent gérer cet
avantage parce qu'elle est vous vous
trier le courrier vous êtes une fan de
claude et c'est parce que vous êtes fan
que vous travaillez au courrier pour
l'approcher tous les jours
quand ils y ont vu autrement le sorbet
on attend en bas du bureau et puis aussi
on va le voir devant chez lui
la main
on va on va les tuer pourquoi les côtés
vous serre la main ça vous fait quoi
snif le plaisir vous vivez en fonction
de lui ah oui vous n'aimez que lui bah
oui
dans les postes et possède beaucoup de
qualités ces cellules il est unique en
son genre alors y'a pas d'autres hommes
dans votre vie que claude non et ça vous
gêne pas qu'il ait des enfants qu'ils
aient des aventures avec d'autres fables
vous n'êtes pas exclusive
bah non c'est normal vous voulez pas
tout à vous mais la personne de claude
serra
[Applaudissements]
la santé
le maire
j'invite à temps
que du beau jeu déjà
j'attendais
oh
en payant
m
toi
ok
[Musique]
congrès
bah
barret
non
ça
ap
à chaque pas
mouillart
m
j'ai vu
moi
[Musique]
m
déjà
bizarre
ah ah
à
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
beaucoup d enfants
c'était un quartier si vous faites en ce
moment tout me dire oui là maintenant
l'heure mais à part ça tout de suite on
s'en doute reconduite ou non mais si des
noms car si vous allez
savent à quel âge avez-vous 27 ans
exactement quelques jours ces vieux ça
déjà on appelle dans les journaux grâce
à l'entente on a entendu à la radio est
à part dieu je vais derniers mois
ça qu'est ce qu'ils disent confiants
alala droit demain soir au visage et
vous demandez comment est ce que vous
envisagez votre carrière plus tard
chantant ça fait dix ans que je fais ça
je vais continuer un bond à l'habitude
de toujours
peut-être moi mais enfin dans son
différemment ne serait-ce claquette par
exemple ça change ça fatigue - surtout
d'accord et vous rester longtemps à la
rambo dan ar braz juste une soirée non
aboli la question et c'est après coup
après je chante en belgique trois
semaines et et vous vous chanter une
chanson we are the champions la dernière
ma carrière le jouet extraordinaire
[Musique]
j'ai fais un petit garçon
plein de vie et de joie un jour que j'ai
est très gentil mon père leur avantage
un jouet d'extraordinaire
avec ce gros 11e
je laisse
[Musique]
l'imposant par terre il faisait aussi
tendue
dans des tours
marchais je ne sais pas
je crois que je ne saurai jamais
comment
tête dès la première fois
quand je les redonnais
j'ai vu qu'il a
sur le peintre de groton porte
tout cela
puis d étirer tout
et quand je leur pose
j'ai ouvert de grands yeux il faisait si
on ne roulait pas d'endettement net des
marchés
je ne sais pas ce que cette année
je crois que je ne saurai jamais
marshall comme un militaire tout
il s'assied
il passa sous une chaise et puis soudain
disparu sous le lit
j'ai pleuré dans l'ict mon père lui rien
car en tournant je vis le souhait qu'ils
étaient des amis guerroyer
il peut écrire quand une roulette pas
dans des tournées
ravis les marchés je ne sais pas ce que
j'ai fait
je crois que je ne saurai jamais sézanne
trop vite et juste
yeah
dans le grenier j'ai retrouvé
je jouais pas
j'ai appelé
et le lait
il est sérieux et
rouillé mais quand dont la base est il
pesait toujours très tôt
marchais je ne sais pas ce que c'est je
crois que je ne serai jamais quand je ne
sais pas ce que c'est je ne saurais
[Musique]